Good afternoon, this
is Dr. Lisa Hoffman.
I'm going to be doing
the DPR lecture today
on behavioral
medicine, the
components of the
patient encounter.
Gonna go over the
objectives for today.
You will be able
to demonstrate
the components
of the history
and physical
exam of a patient
who is presenting with a
behavioral mental
health complaint.
Evaluate the patient
utilizing history taking,
active listening,
facilitated responses,
and, of course,
the physical exam.
Distinguished
normal versus
abnormal encounters
and utilization
of specific
screening measures.
Anticipating and
being able to discuss
common abnormal
encounter findings and
recalling the way to
document history and
examination intake by
writing a SOAP note.
So, again, the
main points of this
lecture, history
considerations for the
patient presenting
with a behavioral
or mental health
issue, physical exam,
osteopathic
treatments if needed,
and soap note writing.
I'm going to go into
the epidemiology
and impact of
mental health before
we get a little
bit further on.
Firstly, the prevalence
of adult mental health.
Of note is one in
five adults in America
experience a mental
illness. In 2019, just
prior to the COVID-19
pandemic, almost 20
percent of adults
experienced a mental illness,
which is nearly 50
million Americans.
More than 50 percent
of adults with
mental health concerns
are receiving no
treatment whatsoever.
We'll go into some
of those reasons a
little bit later.
Almost five percent
of adults report
experienced suicidal
ideation of note
also is that since
the pandemic mood
disorders such as
anxiety and depression
have gone up between
30 to 40 percent
some updated
epidemiological statistics
compiled from the
national institute of
mental health in 2024
for 2025 indicate sadly
that since 2019, since
the COVID outbreak,
the incidence of total
adults experiencing
a mental illness has
increased from 20% to
23%. So mental health
issues has been on
the rise since the COVID
outbreak, which isn't
surprising to most
of us, unfortunately.
And nearly half
of all teenagers
ages 13 to 18 have
also experienced
a mental health disorder.
What has remained the
same, unfortunately,
is that half of
those folks that
have had some type
of mental health
challenges do not
receive treatment.
I'm going to show
you a chart that was
released by NAMI,
the National Alliance
for Mental Illness in
2020, that shows the
prevalence of mental
health by race. I'm
going to zoom in a
little bit for you.
On the right side of
the chart, you can
see that in a 12-month
prevalence of any
mental illness in the
United States adults,
21% of adults have
had a mental illness,
14% of Asian adults,
17% of Black adults,
17% of Native Hawaiian,
18% of Hispanic
or Latino adults,
22% of white
males, and at the
bottom, 44% of the
LGBTQ population.
On the left of the chart,
you can see, again,
12 month prevalence
here of common mental
illnesses and blaring
right in front of you,
you see are the anxiety
disorders at 19%.
You can also see bipolar
is 3% over there,
and you have depression
to the left as well.
so some more
epidemiology of
adults nearly one
in 25 adults in
america live with
mental illness
again 18 percent and
some of these statistics
are a little old
because i just showed
you an updated chart
um this is showing that
18 percent of adults
live with anxiety
disorders excuse me
the chart showed it's a
bit it's a bit elevated
since then uh almost
seven percent live
with major depression
2.6 percent of adults
live with bipolar
disorder approximately
10.2 million adults
have comorbid disorders
both a mental health
and some type of
substance ***** disorder
more than seven
percent of americans
are reporting a
substance use disorder
and of note is that
depression is the leading
cause of disability
worldwide and it's a
major contributor to
the burden of disease.
Of note is depression
is also one of
the leading, untreated
depression is
a leading cause of
suicide as well.
Only 41% of adults
in the United States
with a mental
health condition
actually receive
mental health services.
Approximately
24% of state
prisoners have
a recent history
of a mental
health condition.
Approximately 26%
of homeless adults
staying in shelters
live with serious
persistent mental
illness, SPMI.
Adults in the United
States living with
SPMI typically die
on average 25 years
earlier than
others, and this is
largely due to treatable
medical conditions
that they don't
seek treatment for.
90% of those who
die by suicide
have an underlying
mental illness.
So I wanted to go
into some of the
suicide statistics
in the United States.
First and foremost,
suicide is the
most preventable
cause of death. It's
the eighth leading
cause of death.
Approximately
30,000 to 40,000
people die by
suicide per year.
Five million
living Americans
have made an attempt.
they say one person every
18 minutes
commits suicide.
The United States is
ranked number 27 in
the world of highest
suicide rate and
unfortunately it is
the second or third
leading cause of death
in our youth and that's
typically between
the ages of 15 to 25
and what's startling
about this is
that it's tripled
since the 1950s and
again I said this
before the number
one risk factor
untreated depression
so if we can get
to these folks
early and give
them the treatment
that they need we really
can make a
significant impact
i also want to
inform you guys that
this july 2022
there is an actual
national emergency
line just for mental
health issues it's
going to be 988 so
it should be very
interesting to see
how that pans out,
hopefully for the best.
All right, so we're
going to go into
a little bit of
statistics of mental
health in our youth
and adolescence.
One in five children
ages 13 to 18
have or will have a
serious mental illness.
20% of those live with a
mental health condition.
11% have a mood
disorder and 8%
specifically have
an anxiety disorder.
Suicide is the
third leading cause
of death in our
youths age 10 to 24.
50% of all lifetime
cases of mental illness
begin by age 14 and
75 by age 24. Again,
just showing us
that if we can can
uncover the symptoms
that these patients are
exhibiting and give
them the treatment
that they need, we
can really make a
profound impact on the
quality of life here.
37% of students
with a mental health
condition age 14
and older drop out
of school, and
this is the highest
dropout rate of any
disability group.
And finally,
70% of youth in
state and local
juvenile justice
systems have a
mental illness.
Let's talk about
disparities, racial and
ethnic disparities,
lower rates of health
insurance and less
access to treatment.
In the western states,
southwestern states,
there's actually a
lack of psychiatrists.
So that's been a big
issue where patients
have to travel far
to get the treatment
that they need. And
11% of them with a
mental illness do not
even have insurance.
There's also poor
quality of care.
There's unfortunately
still a staggering
amount of racism,
bias, discrimination
in treatment
settings, language
barriers, and of
course, for still
dealing with stigma
of mental illness.
LGBTQ individuals
are two or more
times likely as
straight individuals
to have a mental
health condition.
11% of transgender
individuals reported
being denied care by
mental health clinics,
largely due to
discrimination.
LGBTQ youth are two
to three more times
likely to attempt suicide
than straight youth.
I also took some more
updated statistics
from the Trevor Report
project in 2021, which
indicated that 70
percent of youth stated
that their mental
health was poor for most
of the time or always
during the pandemic.
48 percent of LGBTQ youth
reported they
wanted counseling
but were unable
to receive it.
So what is the impact
of all of this?
Mental health
disorders increase
risk for suicide,
for comorbidity or
addiction disorders,
incarceration,
homelessness,
joblessness,
having other
medical conditions,
dropping out
of high school.
It's also quite
costly it cost
193.2 billion
dollars in lost
earning every year
in our country
okay we're now going
to move on to how to
evaluate an adult
patient who's presenting
with a behavioral or
mental health complaint
the basic format
of this is pretty
much what you do
with any patient
You, there's an
introduction, you
set the agenda
for the session,
chief complaint
current history, chief
complaint again is
in the patient's own
words, your review
of systems, you
want to assess past
psych history, medical
history, personal
or social history,
of course a physical exam
and any OMM
considerations,
and a summary
and closing.
So your introduction,
you want to set up
a safe environment
for yourself and the
patient. You want to
introduce yourself,
you want to explain
why you're seeing the
patient. You want to
make sure that they
feel safe and as
comfortable as possible.
Of extreme importance
is that you definitely
want to talk about
the nature of the
issue and how it's
extremely sensitive to
talk about mental
health issues and you
definitely want to
assure them about
confidentiality
what goes on in
here stays in here
unless i feel you're
a threat to yourself
or someone else and
finally obviously you
want to gather basic
demos name age date of
birth during the
interview obviously want
to maintain professionalism
at all times
You want to use the
patient's own language
and sort of validate
their feelings
by repeating their
words in your own
statements. It shows
you're listening,
you care, you're
trying to understand.
You also want to
be, try to be aware
of your own biases
when dealing with a
patient with mental
illness. You want
to try to be as
non-judgmental as
possible because you
want the patient to
feel safe and
comfortable to open up.
Otherwise, if
they sense you're
being judgmental,
they're going to
close down. We
don't want that.
You want to educate
and counsel the
patient after you
have gathered the
history and completed
the physical exam.
Okay, observation
of the patient.
How do the patient's
actions or appearance
contribute to what
they're telling you?
So while you're
interviewing this
patient, you want
to constantly
be observant of
the following.
appearance speech patterns
pitch tone behavior
do they really want
to be there or you
can you tell that they
kind of really would
rather be anywhere
else their attitude are
they open to sharing
are they closed shut
down mental status are
they oriented etc posture
are they making good
eye contact or are
they looking down at
the floor and mood and
affect which we will
go into all of this you
should think back to
your cultural competency
and general appearance
dpr lectures for
some more information
so let's move on to
chief complaint in
current history the chief
complaint as said
before is always in the
patient's own words
i've been feeling really
down lately and i just
yeah i can't have i
don't have the energy
to get up and go to
work that's a chief
complaint the HPI, you
always want to use open
-ended questions followed
by closed-ended
questions just to make
sure that you're getting
the clear message.
You always want to
obtain a good timeline
of the patient's
symptoms and concerns.
Did this just
happen? Is this more
acute sentimentology
they're presenting
with, or was this
more of a progression?
If you suspect depression
or anxiety, you
may want to give some
screening measures
like the PHQ-2 or the
PHQ-9 or the GAD, the
Generalized Anxiety
Disorder Screening.
So let's go
over the PHQ-2.
This is a very
brief screening
measure for depression.
It basically asks
Two questions. Over
the last two weeks,
how often have you
been bothered by the
following problems?
Little interest or
pleasure in doing things
or feeling down,
depressed, or hopeless?
You are rated on
a scale for 0 to
4, not at all, several
days, more than
half the days,
nearly every day.
This, again,
is a first-step
approach for depression.
If they score positive,
you definitely
want to give
them the PHQ-9.
So the scores
range from 0 to 6,
and the authors
identified a score
of 3 as the optimal
cutout point,
which is screened
for depression.
So if the score
is 3 or greater,
major depressive
disorder is likely,
and they should
be, as I stated,
further evaluated
with the PHQ-9. So
the PHQ-9, here it
is, is basically
the same thing
I just showed
you, but it has
nine questions.
Again, over the
last two weeks,
how often have
you been bothered
by the following
problems?
One, little
interest or pleasure
in doing things.
Two, feeling
down, depressed,
or hopeless.
Three, trouble
falling asleep,
staying asleep, or
sleeping too much.
Four, feeling tired or
having a little energy.
Five,
poor appetite or
overeating. Six,
feeling bad
about yourself or
that you're a
failure or you let
yourself or your
family down.
Seven,
trouble concentrating
on things such as
reading the newspaper
or watching TV.
Eight, whoops,
here we go. Eight,
moving or speaking so
slowly that other people
could have noticed.
Or the opposite,
being fidgety
or restless
more than usual.
and nine, just move
this down a little bit,
thoughts that you
would be better off
dead or hurting
yourself in some way.
Again, you want to add
up all of the points.
Total scores of
5, 10, 15, and 20
represent cutoff points
for mild, moderate,
moderately severe,
and severe depression.
Obviously, question nine
is sort of a screening
question of suicide
risk. Anyone that
answers yes would need
further assessment
so the interpretation
of this I'm going to
scroll this up for you
you can see anyone who
scores within the range
of zero to four is
minimal or none five
through nine is mild
depression you want
to maybe just sort of
monitor you can repeat
this screening measure
at a follow-up session
10 to 14 is moderate
you should consider
counseling follow-up
possible pharmacotherapy
15 to 19 is moderately
severe you definitely
want to want to
get some treatment in
their pharmacotherapy
psychotherapy and 20
to 27 is severe they
definitely need
immediate treatment
pharmacotherapy
counseling referral
to psychiatrists
psychologists okay the
generalized Anxiety
Disorder is a two
-item scale, the GAD-2.
Again, it's very similar
to the Depression Scale.
Over the last two
weeks, how often have
you been bothered
by the following
problems? Not at all.
Several days, more
than half the days,
and nearly every day.
So number one,
feeling nervous,
anxious, or on edge.
Number two,
not being able
to stop or
control worrying.
So the interpretation
of this is a score of
three points is cut
off for identifying
possible cases, and
you would need further
diagnostic evaluation,
possible generalized
anxiety disorder, and
you definitely should
give further evaluation,
such as the GAD-7,
which is just a seven
item screening tool so
the gad7 is basically
the same thing as the
gad2 but it's it's more
comprehensive right
so over the last two
weeks how often have
you been bothered by
the following problems
number one feeling
nervous anxious or on edge
number two not being
able to stop or control
worrying number three
worrying too much
about different things
four trouble relaxing
five being so restless
that it is hard to sit
still six becoming easily
annoyed or irritable
as if something
awful might happen so
again you add these
all up a score of eight
or greater represents
a cutoff point for
identifying probable cases
of generalized anxiety
disorder further
assessments warranted it
has a sensitivity of 92
percent and basically
any score between zero
and four is minimal
anxiety any score
between five and nine is
mild any score between
10 to 14 is moderate
and a score greater
than 15 really
indicates severe
anxiety so obviously if
you've had you have
anyone in the moderate
and severe they
definitely need a
referral to a psychiatrist
and a psychologist
for medication
and psychotherapy.
Moving forward in
taking current history,
you want to ask when
did the symptoms
begin? Again, acute
versus gradual changes.
Any triggers is
extremely important.
Was it vocational,
personal?
Have the symptoms
changed over time?
Have the patient
describe how they're
feeling or experiencing
it? Does anything make
it better? Does
anything make it worse?
And of significance
is how have
these symptoms
impacted them?
How have they impacted
them in terms of
their functioning
at home, at work, at
school? Because again,
something really
doesn't become a
disorder, right?
Until it impairs their
daily functioning.
And finally,
how have they
been coping with
all of this?
You definitely want
to assess suicide or
homicide risk. Have
they had any thoughts
about hurting themselves
or anyone else?
have they had any
prior attempts at
suicide if yes do they
have a specific plan
a timeline you definitely
want to find out
do they have access
to any type of weapons
or any way in harming
themselves more
specific questions
about suicide what
triggered this was it
planned was it impulsive
did they carry out
their final acts like
write a suicide note
leave a last will
and testament did they
take any precautions
to prevent others
from discovering them
these are all red
flags if they did have
a past suicide attempt
you want to ask
what method of self
-harm was involved how
were they discovered
how did they feel when
help arrived do
they start you know
obviously are they still
feeling suicidal now
many patients who
present with a mental
health issue also may
carry a history of
self-harm or self
-injurious behaviors such
as skin picking
scratching hair pulling
these are called body
focused repetitive
behaviors bfrbs and are
actually in the dsm-5
um cutting burning
you want to
find out if they're
they're self
-medicating abusing
drugs alcohol
these are all
important uh pieces of
history that you
definitely want to obtain
for their past psych
history you want to
ask about other mental
health disorders
the severity any
treatments or medications
you also want to ask
about family psychiatric
history that's very
important see if
there's any genetic
components here and
you want to definitely
ask about previous
psych hospitalization
partial hospitalization
programs specific
treatments such as dbt
dialectical behavior
therapy and others
getting into the
medical history you
want to find out any
past medical history
cert any important
surgeries again
any medications and
of course allergies
as stated before you
want to ask about
any mental health
disorders within the family
any suicide attempts
by any family members
substance ***** you
want to get a feeling
of the patient's role
in the family are they
sort of the the quarterback
do they are they
the caretaker of
everyone how engaged are
they in the family unit
is it supportive if
is it not supportive
you definitely want to
take into religious
ethnic and cultural
factors and what are
their relationships like
are they in an intimate
relationship do they
have a good social
support network do they
have one or two friends
they can confide in
this is really really
crucial information.
Personal history.
You want to find
out about
prenatal, postnatal
complications, any
developmental delays,
childhood, any
school issues,
any learning disorders,
behavioral problems,
bullying, peer pressure,
specific personality
traits, and
you want to look
at that both
in childhood and
in adolescents.
Their social
history. Do they live
alone? Do they live
with family? Do
they live with a
significant other?
What's their
occupation? What's
the highest level
of education?
Do they have any current
or past drug use?
Are they self
-medicating? Very, very
important, right? You see
this a lot in patients
that have anxiety
or depression, that
they're not even aware
that they're actually
self-medicating
you want to assess
assess for current or
past tobacco use and
you want to get a
sense of their ******
history and living
situation who do they live
with if they have
children the children
may be neglected or
witnessing the patient
struggle and they
may need intervention
what type of
relationship are they in
it gives you it
gives you sort of a
feeling of the
interpersonal style and
skills of the patient,
and if there's
conflict there, that's
important to know.
Again, their social
support network, do
they have a good one?
What's the quality
of it? Is it just
sort of superficial
fluff or do they
really have friends
and family that really
have their back?
Is the patient able
to manage all of their
activities of daily
living you'd be
surprised when you start
talking to a patient
who looks really high
functioning and has
a great job and when
you get down to it
they finally tell you
that they don't shower
every day or they
forget to wash their
hair these are all
important factors that
can really tell you
a lot about a patient
their jobs what kind
of jobs do they have
what what are their
dynamics at work? What
are their relationships
like at work?
Are they different at
work versus at home?
How is their stress
level at work?
Do they get into
difficulties with
authority figures? Are
they performing well?
If they're not
working, how are they
coping financially?
Do they have
huge amounts of debt,
which obviously,
you know, increases
stress level?
Do they have a military
background? If so,
what was their
exact experience?
Education. What's
the highest degree
attained? Were
they successful?
Again, any history
of ADHD, any
learning disabilities
ever left back?
These are all
important elements
of getting to
know a patient.
Do they drink alcohol
currently? And how
much do they drink?
You'd be surprised
that people don't even
realize that they've
been drinking a
little bit too much.
You want to ask about
the pattern are they
are they drinking
daily versus just binge
drinking on the
weekends with friends
and another screening
measure you can
use is the the
cage questions if
you feel like they're
drinking a little
bit too much and
you're a little
concerned about
***** and dependence
so this is the
questionnaire for detecting
alcoholism the c
stands for have you
ever felt you should
cut down on your
drinking yes or no
the a have people
annoyed you by
criticizing your drinking?
Yes or no. The G is
have you ever felt
guilty about your
drinking? Yes or no.
The E is have
you ever had a
drink first thing
in the morning,
an eye-opener? Yes or no.
The score of
zero through one
is a low risk
for alcoholism.
Two to three is
a moderate risk,
a moderate to high risk,
and a score of four
is an actual diagnosis
of alcoholism. So
again, it's on a scale
from zero to four.
And obviously,
depending on
this, you can
refer them out for
treatment for
substance *****.
Do they use
recreational drugs?
And if so, which
ones do they use?
A lot of people start
off with *********,
a gateway drug, and
then they obviously
progressively move
on to more serious
substances. How
often do they use it?
How much do they use
of the specific drug.
Do they smoke? Do
they use other tobacco
products? Which ones
do they use? And
how much do they use
on a daily basis?
You also want to
talk a little bit
more about their
****** history,
about how, you
know, the number of
partners they've had
in the last 12 months.
Are they promiscuous?
Are they impulsive?
Do they engage in
risky behaviors?
That's so important
because it just sort of
gives you some insight
into their behavior,
especially their
impulsivity.
Do they use protection?
Review of systems.
You should all be very
familiar with this.
You're asking questions
about main organ
systems to see if
there's some type of
physiological component
or cause to the
psychiatric symptoms.
Cardiovascular,
pulmonary, endocrine,
gastrointestinal
and neurological.
The actual physical
exam, it may be
dependent on
differential diagnosis.
You want to
examine major organ
systems to look for
signs and symptoms
that might be causing the
patient's presenting
complaint. Again,
the same areas,
cardiovascular,
pulmonary, endocrine,
neurological.
We're now going to
move on to the mental
status exam, which
you guys should be
familiar with in your
previous geriatric
lectures, you need to
constantly be observing
as well as listening
to the patient, right,
in order to get a
really good assessment
of the patient. And
there's multiple
elements that we're
going to go into now that
you definitely need
to pay attention to.
These consist of their
state of consciousness.
Are they alert?
Are they awake
their appearance
their general behavior
their attitude
towards you attention
orientation psychomotor
activity are they
fidgety mood affect
speech and language are
they slurred are there
any communication
barriers their form
of thought their
content of thought
perceptions judgment
memory do they have
any insight and their
overall intellectual
functioning which we
will go into a little
bit so for state of
consciousness are they
alert are they hyper
alert are they lethargic
what is what's the
overall impression
you're getting from their
appearance are they
well-groomed how old
do you think they are
what kind of health
do you think they're in
do they look distressed
to you their general
behavior their
gestures any repetitive
behaviors mannerisms
again i stated
this before
eye contact are
they avoidant
they're attitude
towards you are they
cooperative do they not
want to be there remember
some of these patients
are kind of um
pushed into this to see
someone from a loved
one and they really
don't want to be there.
And sometimes it can
be quite obvious.
How is their attention?
How's their
concentration?
Are they oriented?
What's their
psychomotor activity?
Are they agitated?
Any abnormal
movements
you're noticing?
Mood. What is
mood? Mood is
how the patient
says they're
feeling. It's a
stained emotion.
it's their overall
emotional state are they
happy are they depressed
are they anxious
are they irritable
affect is a bit different
than mood affect is
the outward expression
of a patient's inner
emotion it's typically
stated as appropriate
versus inappropriate to
the patient's thoughts
For example, if the
patient just told you
that one of their loved
ones just passed away
and they're laughing
and smiling, that's
inappropriate affect.
Is their affect blunted,
restricted? Is there
no facial expression?
These are all things
that you really need
to pay attention to.
Speech and language.
What's the rate? Is it
pressured? Is it slow?
Is their tone soft? Is it
angry? What
is the volume?
Are they coherent?
And is it age or
culturally appropriate?
Going into their thoughts,
their cognitions.
What is their form
of thought? Are they
circumstantial? Are
they all over the
place? Do they start
on a topic and then
they become very
tangential going somewhere
else? are they guarded
or evasive? That's
very important to sort
of see in a patient
because it really
can help you in
developing a rapport
with the patient or not.
What is the
content of thought?
Are you seeing
any ruminating
phobias, any
ritualistic behaviors?
These things are
obviously all
important
because they can
point to any
psychosis going on.
And their perceptuals.
Any illusions, any
hallucinations?
Are they hearing things,
seeing things
that others can't?
What's their
judgment like?
What's their ability
to come to a good
conclusion on a specific
matter when they
need to choose from
multiple options?
An example of this is
an inebriated patient
decides they're going
to drive home we
often describe this
when writing our notes
judgment is fair
judgment is poor what's
their insight like do
they have awareness
do they recognize
that they're having
these symptoms or
that they might be ill
and are they
actually able to to
attribute their
symptom ontology
to their actual
impairment of functioning
When writing notes,
when we're talking
about insight, we
usually write this as
intact, insight as
intact, or not intact.
What's their memory like?
What's their
immediate recall?
What did they
eat for lunch?
How's their
working memory?
Versus what's their
remote recall?
Who was president
in 1992? to.
You want to get
a sense of their
intellectual
functioning, their
education, their
fund of knowledge.
Are they able to
abstract concepts?
Are they able to perform
more significant,
challenging operations
like calculations?
We're going to
talk a little
bit about differentials.
This all depends
on all the
information you're
gathering from the
history and of
course the the exam.
You want to rule
out physiological
disease or disorders
that could mimic or
cause the patient's
symptoms. So you
want to find out,
is this a medical
issue or is this a
mental health issue?
A big example is
hypothyroidism in patients
with depression.
Often people come in
and say they're
depressed, but then when
they do some blood
work, they find out that
they're actually
their hypothyroidism.
Or a patient with
anxiety has arrhythmia,
which often can
mimic anxiety.
Some diagnostic
tests to consider.
This is dependent on
differentials, but
typically include EKG,
a complete blood count,
which can show if the
patient has an infection,
if they're anemic
if there's any b12
deficiencies a comprehensive
metabolic panel
cmp you want to check
their electrolytes
liver functioning
which can affect their
cognition you want to
check thyroid lipids urine
analysis in geriatrics
a lot of patients
come in and they have
utis which can have
an impact on their
mental status also these
tests give us a baseline
as you guys know
already since medications
can have an effect
on glucose lipids and
heart rhythms some
osteopathic considerations
you want to assess
areas of any somatic
complaints headaches
stomach stomach issues
pain you want to
perform an osteopathic exam
consider the techniques
to normalize the
parasympathetic and
the sympathetic because
you want the body to
get back to healing
itself of course, and
you want to treat
appropriately based off
your exam findings.
Remember, sometimes less
is more, and the patient
may not want this
type of treatment at
this particular time.
Let's talk about
the treatment plan.
You want to explain
to the patient
any differential
diagnosis from the
most likely to the
least likely. You
want to explain
to them in detail
the risks of not
treating an illness.
You want to tell them
what their treatment
options are. Provide
them with education,
counseling, further
testing or therapy. You
want to give them any
referrals, medications.
All of these things
you might not
be that familiar
with because you're
a first-year
student. That's
okay. This is why
we're teaching it.
You want to tell the
patient about benefits
and risks of
treatment. You want to
educate them about
specific medications.
Again, what's really
important is that
collaboration between
yourself and the patient.
Your documentation
after such an encounter
should include
rationale for clinical
tests, EKG, arrhythmia,
for example,
an estimate of the
patient's suicide
homicide risk,
including factors
influencing risk
if needed, your
rationale for
treatment selection.
Why do you think
the patient should
be on this
medication? What are
they presenting
with? What are
the risks? What
are the benefits?
You want to include
a discussion
of the specific
factors that
influence the
treatment choice.
Like I said, why
are you doing
this? And of
course, you always
want to include
follow-up plans.
Should the patient come
back in six months,
three months? Which
office? Should they
see you every week?
Should they see you every
other week? You want
to be very specific
with follow-up plans,
and you want to make
sure you're documenting
this appropriately.
Finally, I wanted
to give you a little
example of an
outpatient psychiatric
clinic note. It's
a little template.
Again, just as a
reminder, you guys have
learned about this in
previous DPR lectures so
the soap is an acronym
right the s is subjective
that's where the
clinician or physician
describes his or her
impressions of the client
and what you what you
understood the client
to say what were
their present what was
their presenting problem
what are their current
symptomatology for
example mr a reported
that he's sleeping two
to three hours a night
he noted feeling sad
crying intermittently
and having suicidal
ideation the o is for
objective that's a factual
account of what you
observed as the physician
in this room with
a patient presenting
with a mental health
issue for example mr a
appeared lethargic he
really made eye contact
his affect was flat
and he spoke only
when queried the a is
assessment this is a
synthesis of the subjective
and objective portion of
the note that includes
diagnosis and your
clinical impressions.
For example,
Mr. A appears to
be experiencing
a major depressive
episode.
Finally, the
P is for plan.
This is where you
describe exactly
what your
treatment plan is.
Mr. A will be referred
for a medication
evaluation. He has been
put on suicide watch.
He will be seen again
tomorrow for further
assessment again this
is just an example from
an outpatient psychiatric
clinic everyone's
is going to look slightly
different but this
is the the general
format for a soap note
i'm going to provide
you with some summary
and references here
again just to summarize
mental health disorders
obviously have
a strong societal and
personal impact we
are definitely in
the midst of a mental
health crisis, and
it's substantially
gotten worse since
the pandemic hit.
Again, you know, 30
to 40 percent increase
of mood disorders
is very significant.
And it's important
that the history that
you gather from a patient
is as thorough and
individualized
as possible.
You want to make sure
that you're including
a proper mental
status assessment,
as well as ruling out
any other underlying
medical or chronic
conditions.
That is the end of our
lecture. I hope you
found this helpful.
I'm putting up some
references here for
you guys if you would
like to do any further
studies on any of
these topics that we
discussed here today.
There's a bunch
of references.
If you have any
questions, again,
I'm Dr. Hoffman.
Here is my email.
Please feel free to
reach out to me with
any questions
that you have. I
would be happy to
answer them for you.
Again, I hope you found
this lecture helpful.
Please don't forget to
fill out the
feedback form.
Thank you so much.